let's talk about a dark topic that
you're one of the world experts in
kidnapping you so you teach courses on
counter kidnapping and terrorism
I read an estimate that criminal gangs
get 500 million dollars a year in Ransom
payments from kidnapping it's just at a
high level what is kidnapping who does
it and why what are some insights that
can help
us understand what is this problem in
the world it happens in different ways
in different parts of the world I mean I
just sent off a group of people that
trained some of the ukrainians and some
of the stuff that they were show they
were showing them was some of the
counter custody stuff that I showed them
a friend of mine named Vince went out
there was showing them some of the
aspects of how to utilize things like
Kevlar cordage and how to infuse it in
their uniform so if they get uh zip tied
to cut them open it's a war setting so
it talks about being captive in a war
zone but the information or the
methodology actually comes from Mexico
that methodology as far as how I learned
it in terms of how to escape from
strands yeah so in Mexico you have
abductions happening where uh cartels uh
who hold control over a specific place
or Zone
um are having a hard time uh with
financial situations as far as maybe
they're not making enough money to pay
everybody off so they let them freelance
basically and a lot of ways some of
these criminal groups freelance or some
of these groups actually professionalize
in to abduct businessmen abduct the sons
of businessmen or people that have money
to ask for ransoms for them basically
and uh they've taken
you know captivity and abduction to like
an art form in places like Mexico and
has a history all over the world but uh
specifically my experience with it with
it was going to
uh cartel safe houses that turned into
holding places you would see you know
homemade prison cells and stuff like
that and people being held in captivity
for months if not years
as they were milking their family for
everything they owned so it turns out
into a business they're not actually
even interested in hurting the people
physically they're interested in hurting
them
uh financially financially and also this
if they get hurt they're hurt for a
purpose which is to make their family
pay up faster or more uh some of the
abduction groups that I've seen out
there professional ones in Mexico
basically make it a living to Target
people that have abduction insurance or
that work for companies that have good
abduction insurance so it's it's almost
like an ATM for them you know it's like
ah hero again huh so there's some of
that going on uh some not so much some
abductions are expressed I mean I'll
grab you with a and gunpoint take you to
an ATM you empty it out and then you're
on your way that's an Express kidnapping
that might not be worth you doing
anything insane you know you just go
with the motions
um but some people do get picked up you
know uh I have trained people with prior
experiences of abductions in Mexico and
here in the United States people that
have spent some time in captivity with
loved ones here like ex-boyfriends or
boyfriends that tie them up and beat the
[ __ ] out of them
and the restraints that utilize are zip
ties and handcuffs sometimes or duct
tape or their own clothing things of
this nature basically what somebody's
looking for when they tie anybody up is
to convince you that they are in control
that they are God and that any hope of
you releasing the restraints or getting
out of that situation is hopeless
from a cartel group picking you up in
the middle of uh dirt road somewhere in
Cancun to uh ex-boyfriend showing up at
your house and tying you up till you
agree to get back with them that's the
same thing
uh and some of the restraints that are
being utilized come from different
places I mean I remember as an
instructor I had way back when told me
that the proliferation of zip ties is a
restraint in criminal abductions came up
after the movie Heat came out because
everybody wanted to be Robert De Niro
zip dying people in the bank robbery at
the end of the movie criminal saw that
and it became like hilarious can you
actually speak to the is it possible to
systematically learn how to escape
restraints like handcuffs rope zip ties
the best at it or not the military the
not see your program people they are
criminals I learned how to get a
handcuffs from a 15 year old who was in
charge of meth sales and in uh
revolution in Tijuana is there a system
to it I mean it's not specifically a
system it's uh usually what they what
happens is they'll buy a set of
handcuffs and they will mess around with
them in a playing feature so
one thing I do in a class is first off
I'm honest about the fact that some you
know all the restraints are temporary
even marriage
this is this is like wait can we just
pause on the Deep philosophical you're
like Yamoto Musashi with that statement
all all restraints are temporary even
marriage uh I'll just uh just I just
like adding that one in there for last
because this is a dark subject every
cage can be escaped all restraints are
temporary you you either free yourself
from the restraints somebody else takes
them off or you die and your body rots
your way around them you know those are
the options
um and I like that first option myself
the second option is pretty cool if you
can convince somebody to do that for you
but that first option is an interesting
one
you have to deconstruct restraints not
all restraints are made the same uh you
can train to get out of handcuffs here
in the US and you know focus on a pair
of Smith and Western handcuffs which are
kind of the most common brand of
handcuffs here
but if you find yourself in detention
somewhere in Russia the handcuffs out
there are completely different you know
the key way is different the mechanism
is different but some of the same ways
of bypassing those mechanisms are write
this down so in Russia what kind are
they using to run they're going to
travel in there I need this information
I'll send you a specific model and
details on how to get out of those uh
but basically asking for a friend I'm
sorry so what I do is I I take I take a
pair of Smith and Wesson handcuffs I put
them in the middle of uh of three people
in the in a class I spread them out and
I have them place them on each other in
a just playing manner I have Hank I have
handcuffed Keith there and I have a pair
of bolt cutters there in case somebody
gets stuck does something stupid so they
they play with each other as far as
putting them on randomly I show them how
to put them on appropriately and then I
show them a handcuff key and a handcuff
key will open up handcuffs interestingly
enough but the thing about a handcuff
key is it's not made to be used by the
person that is in those handcuffs
so that's the first lesson there
if you have a hank of key handcuff keys
are the most used tool to open up
handcuffs in custody situations you know
both criminals escape from the police to
people escaping from criminals just a
standard hidden handcuff key so I show
them how to modify the Handcuff key so
it's more optimal to use on yourself
with just basic garbage that you can
find piece of wire a zip type piece
basically how to put a leverage arm on
the Handcuff key so you can actually
spin it in the key way behind your back
or in front of you
trying to think I don't think I've ever
been in handcuffs uh appropriate way to
handcuff somebody's Palms out how much
restriction is there in terms of there's
a lot if it's a it's a hinge handcuffed
there's a lot of restriction
can you reach back you could try and
reach back or you can basically put
yourself in a not compromised position
and feed the most of your palm meat into
the Handcuff way so when they shut it
shut it on you you have more space to
work with so you can spin your hand we
call it a passive resistance again you
go through a process within where you
deconstruct how people are handcuffed
handcuff keys and how to modify hand
cookie to be able to use on yourself and
these all of these things they're
constructing as we go so they basically
hey what's a grinding surface well
there's concrete outside so they grind
and angle on the key so you can get a
key not to go straight into the keyway
but you can get it into the key we had
an angle for example it's something
that's something that is out there as
far as a method
you can't spin a key behind your back
because it's small it's designed to be
used by somebody else opening those
handcuffs on you so you put an arm on it
so you can leverage our arm so you can
spin it behind your back
you learn how to put yourself in not a
compromised position if somebody asks
you for your hand cut or your hands so
they could be cuffed you don't do this
you know you do that or you put yourself
in a cable grip behind your back which
is a pretty strong grip and it's hard to
spread those hands apart it's also
something that people go into
automatically when they're in fear so
all these things are advantageous for
you
and you learn how not only people get
restrained but you see videos of them
because I show a bunch of abduction
that's actually happening live
again the best thing is avoidance but
specifically when you work around
restraints is number one learn how some
of these restraints work
number two is learning how some of the
ready-made tools to get out of the
restraints look like function
and number three which is the advanced
level is learn how to construct all
these things yourself which is I think
that is the that is the best thing you
can show somebody
for handcuffs I just use a standard pair
of handcuffs and then we deconstruct
other very specialized handcuffs that
might be out there and you show them if
you're going to travel somewhere learn
what restraints are commonly in the
available in the environment somebody
going to the north sub-Saharan Africa
carrying a plastic handcuff key is
that's going to be useless out there
because there's not going to be standard
handcuffs out there that would be
open with that type of key out there
you're probably going to be tied up with
a chain and a padlock of some sort maybe
a 40 millimeter Chinese padlock with a
plastic core that you can open with a
a lighter if you can burn the core melt
the core open or if you can leverage
that open that's a pretty easy thing to
open or a bobby pin you could reach all
the way in the back and open the latch a
little
rope
uh a common yeah it is common uh this is
one of my favorite things for rope
something I usually carry in some places
it's another gift for you if you want
it's a ceramic razor blade nice is it
capable of cutting
nice that small uh you can put it behind
a label I've seen some students put the
Levi's label on there and just sew it
back on
um it is non-magnetic non-ferrous so in
and out of uh you know that type of
situation you can get in and it's
something you can have with you
everywhere
this is a pretty fancy one or you can
just grab a simple razor blade actually
learning how to use or leverage a razor
blade between your palms and
know how to go up and down with it to be
able to cut yourself of course so that's
just practice to do that well it's
practice and it's also exposure to just
this is a possibility this is how you
can hide it again the whole smuggling
aspect comes from a criminal uh criminal
mindset type setting so how how things
are hidden where they're hidden and when
I talk about concealing objects of this
nature it usually comes from
smuggling you know the fact that I have
something in a notebook comes from
heroin smuggling
if you're not looking at the school of
criminality you're missing out on a big
part of the equation
so for people who want to learn about
this do you teach courses on this do you
know what's the right what's the wreck
how do you get in touch with you or
learn from you do you have stuff online
or is it only so I have some stuff on my
patreon uh specifically I have a patreon
where I share a lot of the
online material like basically a bunch
of this is my notebook I have a bunch of
stuff that I I just met somebody in
Philadelphia that showed me a pretty
unique way of utilizing a box cutter as
a weapon so I wrote some of that down I
filmed some of it
um and it's not for any other reason I'm
not trying to create dangerous people
out there it's like hey look at this
this is something that's out there right
um so a lot of that information some of
those notes and stuff like that I keep
on my patreon I used to share it openly
on Facebook and Instagram but that uh
that has not uh been possible anymore
well I'm a member your patreon and
recommend people signing up it's really
great because you also have philosophy
you're you're you're the you're the uh
the Mexican Miyamoto Musashi uh so it's
not just these skills it's also the
philosophy around it like I got that
that book of five rings before I went
into training like I took that with me
through training the whole aspect of you
know go to places uh frightening to the
common brand of men you know be put in
jail and extricate yourself with your
own wisdom I think he was speaking about
experiencing experience you know the
whole Warriors journey of the hero's
journey of going out there and actually
risking
um I think that's a pretty
big basis and aspect of what the work I
do and showing some of these things
there's a tendency to people say hey I'm
afraid to go to Mexico uh what do I need
to know like well if you're afraid to go
to Mexico to go to Mexico
um I mean I was in Detroit I was pretty
afraid when I was in Detroit in some
parts of Detroit and uh the South Side
Chicago
um but uh
I don't want to be dictated where I can
go and where I can't go because of
safety I want to take responsibility for
that myself and figure out ways of being
more capable and an asset to the people
around me and myself
and that comes to experience
and people don't want to risk getting a
shoulder injury rolling in Jiu Jitsu or
don't want to risk getting a bloody nose
and boxing but that is the way